presented by movies anywhere your movies
together at last download the movies
anywhere app today and bring your movie
collection together
from the bros behind Deadpool envenom
comes the louder Dumber murican version
of Shaun of the Dead
more like you've got red white and blue
on you
USA USA Zombieland it's been two months
since the zombie apocalypse ravaged
civilization and everything's going
pretty good actually the roads are clear
the power still on someone put in the
code for infinite ammo and there aren't
even any zombies now that I'm thinking
about it - this is like the easiest
apocalypse since wall-e and one of us
the drummer's 20 related I could use a
20 the last box of Twinkies that anyone
will enjoy Twinkie Twinkie Twinkie
Twinkie lord willing a GD Twinkie you
know what they call Twinkies in Mexico
lo submarino's it's been only like two
months man a Twinkie a year is plenty do
you like zombie stuff but wish he wasn't
weighed down by social commentary played
character driven drama or any horror at
all well stick a Twinkie of my butt and
call me woody because this woman of zom
calm is all killer and no filler that
silly as it may be is ten times more fun
than whatever's happening on Walking
Dead these days even baseball bad guys
boring now yikes prepared for the film
equivalent of a michelin-starred chef
cooking a McRib in an 82 minute popcorn
movie where every actor is oscar-worthy
with Jesse Eisenberg's first outing as
an emotionally stunted bird boy who
thinks he's smarter than everyone else
abigail breslin doing her best to D
Sunshine herself Emma Stone in those
giant bangs every actress was required
to have at the time Woody Harrelson as
the state of Florida
and Bill Murray who drops in to remind
everyone they could be watching
Ghostbusters instead all combining for a
film that kind of feels like a bunch of
zombie themed sketches or TV episodes
stitched together because that was the
original idea
so sue de rossabi raw that's very much a
product of 2009 World of Warcraft do ya
Code Red
Facebook status updates she's wearing
the wig but hit big because it was meta
before Deadpool did zombies before the
genre collapsed and came out at a time
free of all that forced world building
before every universe had to expand into
sequels and spin-offs and oh well I
guess it's time that zombie genre got
its Blues Brothers 2000 star age you
know it's cooler than a billion friends
three friends there's gonna be carnage
bah bah brains
Punkie boom stir amber alert the
haunting of Bill's house
Luthor v Joker coming to theaters 2022
and the first will of bike club is there
a lot of rules in bike club did you
really have to write these down while
these are just common sense my guy
brains world brains world
party time excellent
I know you have zombies but paper money
is disgusting and you have zombies and
pinkeye hey screen junkies did you know
we made a documentary about Galaxy Quest
it even has Tim Allen in it oh your
commander is on deck
click on the left to see the full
trailer and on the right to learn how to
see the full documentary this episode
was brought to you by movies anywhere
you choose where to purchase your
favorite movies we'll bring them
together in one place movies anywhere
download the app today